how to maintain
success so this is a great question that
i got from one of my readers
novres who wrote in to say thanks for
the video evan i got a question is it
possible to do a video
based on how you can maintain success
this is a great question and if you want
to maintain success
the key is you need to evolve and
innovate a lot of times entrepreneurs
they start a business they start seeing
some success they start getting sales
they start getting market penetration
they start getting market share
and then you see the company start to
plateau you know you're here
you're just stable and then you start
seeing the company decline
and this happens with most companies
look at how many companies have lasted
100 years or longer
and there aren't that many most
companies shut down they fail they can't
transfer to another generation
they can't maintain their success
because they don't
evolve and innovate the reality is your
market is going to change
right you discover a secret right you
you discover a hole in a market
something that is missing and you fill
it with your product or service that's
great and it works for a while
but you've got to change it over time
right you've got to continue to add to
it because the market is going to change
and if you don't keep up with it
your company is going to suffer you
can't keep doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
again okay look at blockbuster
right they had the the video stores you
know go go there rent a video
bring the dvd back and then came along
the internet and then came along
netflix and blockbuster had a chance to
buy netflix
and that deal didn't work out and now
blockbuster is out of business they had
a great concept it was working for a
long time they made a lot of money
but they didn't innovate or evolve and
the company went under
really quickly and that's what happens
to a lot of companies so
to get to a successful point is hard
enough but to maintain it is harder
because you need to keep
innovating and evolving when you don't
do that two things happen
one as i mentioned your company suffers
right you stop coming up with new ideas
and your company starts to stagnate
flat sales then starts to decline but
the second part is
you become bored you know as an
entrepreneur
entrepreneurs we're addicted to the new
right we come up with new ideas we're
the visionaries
we we have this idea of what we want to
create and then it's fun to put it into
place and to start to see it grow
we don't want to just maintain this
boring company we want to come up with
new things
and so when you're not doing that as a
company it hurts your business but it
also hurts you like it hurts your soul
as an entrepreneur not to be coming up
with new things to help your customers
out
so you want maintain success continue to
evolve
and innovate believe those are watching
love to know what you think leave a
comment below click on the link in the
description to support me
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much i'll see you
soon